jacques fue en un submarino hasta el
fondo del mar y descubrió una ciudad
submarina padrísimo no en esa ciudad
submarina las estrellas de mar
gobernaban la ciudad y había 59
caballitos de mar pero esos 59
caballitos de mar son 28 menos que el
número de estrellas de mar y lo que
queremos saber es cuántas estrellas de
mar había entonces cuántas estrellas de
maravilla pues vamos a volver a ver todo
lo que nos dice tenemos por aquí que
había 59 caballitos de mar pero que esos
59 caballitos de mar son 28 menos que el
número de estrellas de mar entonces el
número de caballitos de mar
es 28 menos que el número de estrellas
de mar entonces el número de caballitos
de mar es igual al número de estrellas
de mar número de estrellas de más
menos 28 menos 28 porque el número de
caballitos de mar es 28 menos que el
número de estrellas de mar y bueno de
hecho también nos dicen cuál es el
número de caballitos de mar nos dice que
había 59 caballitos de mar así es que
podemos escribir por aquí 59 que es el
número de caballitos de mar y eso es
igual al número de estrellas de mar
menos 28 el número de estrellas de más
menos 28 menos 28 y bueno otra forma de
pensar en esto es que nos están diciendo
que hay 28 estrellas de mar más que el
número de caballitos que hay y entonces
podemos escribir que el número de
caballitos de mar sea cual sea es el
número que resulta ser 59 59 hay 28
estrellas de mar más entonces el número
de caballitos de mar le tenemos que
sumar 28 para obtener el número de
estrellas de mar número de estrellas de
mar
ok porque hay 28 estrellas de mar más de
lo que hay caballitos de mar y bueno
siempre que estamos haciendo un problema
de este tipo es una muy buena idea
preguntarse si hay más caballitos de mar
o más estrellas de mar y eso es algo que
podemos ver aquí porque nos dicen que
había 59 caballitos de mar y que esos
son 28 menos que el número de estrellas
de mar o sea que nos están diciendo que
hay menos caballitos de mar que
estrellas de mar nos están diciendo que
hay 28 - que podemos concluir que hay
más estrellas de mar y entonces podemos
ver que esto de aquí tiene sentido
porque el número de caballos de mar le
vamos a sumar 28 para obtener el número
de estrellas de mar porque hay más
estrellas de mar que caballitos de mar
entonces ya nada más tenemos que
averiguar cuánto es 59 28
y vamos a hacer esto por aquí ahí
tenemos 59 caballitos de mar 59 que son
cinco decenas y nueve unidades a eso le
queremos sumar 28 que son dos decenas y
ocho unidades
así es que ponemos las decenas en el
lugar de las decenas y a las unidades en
el lugar de las unidades vamos a sumar
esto de aquí ya estamos tomando el
número de caballitos de mar y le estamos
sumando 28 para obtener el número de
estrellas de mar
entonces empezamos por el lugar de las
unidades 9 unidades más 8 unidades son
17 unidades lo cual se puede reagrupar
como 7 unidades y una decena también
podemos decir que tenemos 7 y llevamos
una pero lo único que estamos haciendo
es reagrupar el 17 en siete unidades y
otras diez unidades que es una decena y
ahora simplemente sumamos las decenas o
sea que sumamos uno más cinco más dos y
uno más 52 son ocho entonces el número
de estrellas de mar que había eran 87
pero bueno uno siempre tiene que checar
su respuesta así es que vamos a ver el
número de estrellas de mar estamos
diciendo que son 87 y hay 59 caballitos
de mar que son 28 menos que el número de
estrellas de mar así es que nos tenemos
que preguntar si 59 es
28 menos que 87 pero pues claro que sí
porque de hecho eso es lo que usamos
para resolver este problema